In the 1790s only two countries existed:
Kingdom of Scotland and Kingdom of England.
England and other European powers were serving themselves well and expanding
Their empires by the furtive use of their flags.
Scotland was not an empire but wanted to join the game, so I needed to create
Colony of its own.
But where do you build them?
"Panama" announced by Scotland.
I thought that the strategic location of the colony would make trade with the Far East safer
And speeding down the long journey around the Cape of Good Hope and Cape Horn
Where both winds and waves help break ships on rocks and ice.
"Who will lend me money to make this great idea a reality?" I asked Scotland.
No one, that was the answer.
Instead of helping, European empires began a trade war with Scotland to reduce power
Their future rivals.
So, Scotland alone has to fund the project itself. She collected all the money she could,
Literally it was put into a large box, and so the capital was collected, and the ship was sent
Colonialism.
400,000 pounds, 8,000 miles and after 111 days, 2500 Scots arrived for beaches
Panama, and renamed it "New Caledonia" and immediately discovered some minor problems
In their plan:
First, the mountains on the western side of Panama were slightly larger than expected,
Making wild trade impossible. Even if they think of building a channel,
The technology to do so is still 200 years from discovery.
Second, the woolen products they brought for trade with local people were ultimately useless
With heat and humidity.
Thirdly, the Spanish colonists had already placed their flags on the sandy beach and were not
Very happy with the arrival of the Scots.
Fourthly, without adequate supplies, diseases such as tropical mites, diarrhea,
It began to spread.
After two years and 2,000 Scottish deaths, they decided to abandon the project.
Now, this was not the first unsuccessful attempt in the Scottish Empire, old colonies were formed
Her experience and abandonment in Nova Scotia, New Jersey and Caroline, but Panama specifically was a disaster
Devastating to Scotland because of over-investment.
Remember that money in the fund? It turned out that he was a fifth state fortune.
Excuse me.
Scotland's sudden poverty proved the golden opportunity of the Kingdom of England
Which is increasingly concerned that its northern neighbor may ally itself with
enemy.
England offered Scotland an agreement to compensate for its losses if they voted for
the Union. In 1707 Scotland was approved and the Kingdom of Great Britain was born.
While giving up independence was unpopular in Scotland, its economy improved with the arrival
One of the English trade lines (now British) and played a founding role in what will be known
Soon the largest empire in human history.
However, after more than 300 years, Scotland did not give up altogether
National identity and ideas of independence.